hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the night fork
bait trap it arrives from the king's
gambit which is my favorite opening in
all of chess
e45 f4 now i typically hope my opponent
is going to accept the king's gamut on
f4 but they don't always there's a lot
of decline lines and a lot of players
prefer
declining the king's gambit one of the
most annoying lines that i face is the
classical defense and that is bishop c5
because
it stops white from castling on the
king's side which is a very very common
theme that you see in the king's gambit
is you cash on the king side you have
your rook on the f
file and your rook is really a huge
attacker on this ephile and then your
king is over here on g1 and it's fairly
safe even though your f pawn's not there
so bishop c5 fairly common we're going
to play knight f3 definitely don't want
to capture on
e5 here be a huge mistake because after
h4 from the queen we have to play g3 and
then
just a huge blunder for
white so we're going to continue with
the main
theme in the king's
gambit and that is just knight to f3
definitely want to protect this h4
square they play d6 this is really how
fisher approached the king's gambit from
black standpoint always playing that d6
solidify the pawn chain open up for the
light squared bishop this is thought to
be almost the king's gambit killer here
with the d6
white now plays knight to c3 and then we
have knight to f6 attacking the e4
square bishop to c4 attacking this f7
square from black then we could see
knight c6 pawn d3 since they played d3
we're now opening up for our own dark
square bishop to get involved into the
game
and now they play bishop g4 now i like
to always represent how often you will
see
uh these particular moves bishop to c5
definitely one of the more common
decline lines that you'll see this
specific situation
uh it's not the most common of all the
lines that you'll see even in the
classical defense so want to make sure
that you recognize that i just feel like
it's always important to to study traps
to see what threats that you have
especially in the kings gambit knowing
that you're giving up material for these
threats really understanding all the
different dynamics and how they work i
think it's just very important to study
so before everyone leaves a comment it
just says oh this will this will never
happen uh definitely not the most common
definitely can happen not going over any
moves that are that are radical by any
means but i do think it's one both fun
but then also
as you're just learning how to attack in
the in the king's game it uh this
definitely will help you as you're
starting to strategize and getting more
matilla involved into the game so after
bishop g4 you you can start to see we're
laying a trap here pawn to h3
the bishop takes we're going to capture
with our queen and we're inviting them
this is all leading up to
hopefully they see the move knight d4
which is a very good move you can see
it's a great outpost for this knight on
d4 it's attacking not only the queen but
it's also attacking the pawn on
c2 which would be a fork it would attack
both the king and the rook on a1 but you
can probably tell
from the title of the video the night
fork bait trap we're gonna allow them
we're gonna bait them into actually
capturing the pawn and forking our rook
that's gonna be fine with us because
we're really trying to just get more
material involved into the game and
attack our opponents right now weaken
king's side because they have not
castled so we're going to play queen 2
g3
we're going to allow our opponent to
take on c2 we're going to play king d1
and then after rook takes on a one we're
going to go ahead and exchange with the
pawns in the center of the board and
then we're going to take on a g7 we
recognize that many times in the kings
game it the the rook on a1 doesn't do a
whole heck of a lot
so in this case hey we're gonna allow
our opponent to move the knight
one two three four times down to a1
take a piece we don't always use that
much for a very very strong attack
you can see the threat that white has
queen takes on f7 checkmate so pretty
logical for black just to play rook to
f8 and now white gets the rook involved
with rook to f1 same concept in the
king's gambit getting the rook to f1
really trying for a strong attack on
this f7 square we have the bishop the
queen and the rook all eyeing down the
f7 square and while we haven't castled
the king's pretty safe uh the queen's
not on a light square that the king is
on light square so it's not going to be
attacking from the diagonal the queen
can come down to d3 but right now that
d3 square is protected by the bishop we
do have to keep in mind that it can come
down here and black does not have a
light square bishop so it can't attack
our king on a light square from a
diagonal as
well
you can also see that we're adding more
pressure on this f6 square so black
really should be protecting that
bringing the bishop back to e7 but we
can also get another attacker with
bishop g5 and we're now overloading this
piece on f6 the queen the bishop and the
rook three attackers on the f6 square
black only has two defenders with the
bishop and the queen so how does black
really respond to this we're going to
look at this position and look at all
the different scenarios that black has
to defend
knowing that the knight will fall if it
just stays as is one option that black
has is to play knight to h5 because it
gets the knight out of the way it also
attacks the queen on g7 the problem is
this would be a huge blunder for black
they should absolutely not do this but
want to go over if they continue to fall
deeper and deeper into the trap they
already fell for the knight to a1 giving
us a very very strong attack on the king
side but if they continue down and don't
play optimally it's always good to know
how to respond because knight to h5
while it does attack the queen that's
not our real threat we have bishop takes
on
f7 now how do they respond to this one
if they just take
okay well that's fine we play queen to
f7 because remember the rook is
protecting that f7 square king d7 and
then knight to d5 and you can start to
see all the threats the bishop is being
pinned down by the queen uh this knights
and the bishop are both attacking this
bishop as well as the queen is
a lot a lot of threats that we have
going on here gonna be very difficult
for black to hold on if they don't take
our bishop they could just play king to
d7
but from here we can take the pawn on e5
and we have a lot of threats from here
if they play king to c8 potentially
we play knight to d5
with a lot of threats as well still same
thing the knight and the bishop and the
queen are all eyeing down this e7 square
we also have our rook that we can get
involved the king is fairly trapped here
we also have threats of eventually
coming to c7 can't do that right away
because they're protecting it with their
queen but we have a lot of threats there
if they just play
king 2
c6
okay well now we can come over here with
uh b5 really forcing them and then we do
have uh checkmates here with queen to uh
d5 so they're just in a really really
tough spot if they decide to play knight
to
h5 now if they don't play the knight
what is really the threat that white has
let's take a look for
at rook 2 c8 okay well we can take that
knight on f6 remember we're overloading
that piece and so they're really in a
tough spot if they take it back we can
take with our rook here
and they don't have a lot of good
responses queen to d7 trying to hold on
to the f7 square but we just have two
mini pieces now we have another bishop a
rook and a queen
once we move the bishop we do have to
keep in mind the bishop was guarding the
pawn on d3 so the queen at some point
can take that pawn and we are in a world
of hurt so we have to make sure that we
are attacking the black king so they are
in check
now how do they really respond to that
okay well if they play king 2 d8 well
that's going to be checkmate because
king to f8 and then okay pretty quick
checkmate there so that's not going to
work
what if they take with their rook
okay well now we come up with queen two
g8 they stop that but then you can see
it's going to be
checkmate as well
the best option for them
is to take with their queen
queen takes on f7 but you can see this
is pretty bad because now they're just
going to lose that queen
and now we can come back with queen to
e5
they don't have their knight involved
into the game remember knight on a1 not
doing anything it can't come to b3 or c2
both of those are just going to lose the
knight and so after
rook to e7 potentially queen h5 then we
can play knight d5 and a queen and a
knight in an attack versus just two
rooks which one of those rooks isn't
doing too much
definitely going to be a huge advantage
for white
now if we come back to this position
again the optimal play from black is to
play
queen d4 and the reason for that is it
opens up for black to castle on the
queen's eye remember the king is under
attack it's in the center of the board
there's so many different threats
that they're gonna be in a lot of
trouble if they cannot castle
and white can't play you know we've
already looked at bishop to f7 hey you
know check but it really just stops
after rook two f7 because
the knight's still here
usually we have the rook on f1
that's attacking and defending the f7
square we don't have that anymore
and so now all of a sudden white's
attacks are really gone the queen can't
come to
you know g8 it would fall to the knight
can't come back to h8 because then just
the rook comes back that's not gonna
work as well
and then all of a sudden you see things
starting to fall apart and the bishop on
c4 is no longer protecting the pawn on
d3 so really
white can't take on f7 they're just
gonna take on f6
which is fine but now black can castle
on
the queen side and we're gonna come back
to g4 attacking the king the king is
going to come to b8
we're going to take
this bishop on e7
but then they're going to take our
bishop on c4 now
remember as soon as they take
that bishop the pawn
is a huge liability because the queen
can take now the pawn can't take the
queen because it's being pinned down by
the rook so that's why it's like hey
yeah that that bishop's protected but
it's really not we can't take it with
our pawn but also black has the threat
of queen to d3 so we can't just take
with our bishop it'd be really nice to
just take
you know on f8 or d8 it doesn't really
matter which one here they're going to
play queen to d3 and then we're going to
lose two checkmates so we can't actually
take one of
the rooks right away we we need to play
king 2
c1
avoiding the queen coming to
uh d3 but this also opens up the ability
to take the queen on
d or c4 so they need to go ahead and
take that pawn and that's fine because
now we can take with our bishop on f8
and it looks kind of crazy because
they have the queen the rook and the
knights but they actually don't have a
clear-cut way to
continue their assault and we still have
a lot of very powerful pieces we have
more minor pieces with an extra bishop
and we have some strong attacks on the
king this is going to be an absolute
wild ending of a game but that's if
black plays optimally coming back and
playing that queen to d4
early in that position when we come to
this spot so that is the night fork bait
trap
always looking for fun traps in the
king's gambit line so
if you come to this position and they
play that knight to
d4 with an outpost you can say you know
what go ahead you're attacking my queen
i'm not even gonna retreat back to d1
which seems pretty logical and protect
that pawn on c2
i'm gonna let you go ahead and have it
i'm gonna come over to g3
let you go ahead and take my rook on a
one and i'm just gonna start attacking
your king side with queen takes on g7 so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
definitely seems like you're enjoying
these trap videos let me know what you
think if there's other videos you want
to see or if you want me to continue
making these as well if you have options
for other videos feel free to leave
those in the comment section below or if
there's just openings in general that
you like traps i like a lot of kings
gambit but if there's others if you like
the rye lopez or the queen's gamut or
the car con or anything else if you say
hey find some cool traps in this opening
i'll definitely make sure to add some
videos on those as well thank you guys
so much for watching the video i'll see
you next time